I'm holding coffee in my hand so we're
gonna use this for a very quick demo
right at the start let's see if I just
do this I'm gonna take a handful of
coffee granules drop them and we get a
pattern that looks like that let me get
rid of the rest of them question is is
that random what do you think Brody I
guess we could even ask you know do the
coffee grins stick together somehow does
that cause them to cluster is that you
know giving rise to some of the
parenting but the interesting thing is
we can eyeball it and often you know
physicist or as bad as many other people
in the the libel of a part run and go
yeah it looks pretty random to me but
actually how do you work out if it's
random and what do I mean by random what
I mean are the points uncorrelated is
there no relationship between the
positions of the grains are they
entirely unrelated there's one thing
that connects all scientists regardless
of the discipline physicists chemists
biologists it's that we look for
patterns that's you know a lie during
data in time or in space and we try to
look for correlations we try to look for
relationships but the problem is we can
be as easily fooled as everybody else
despite all our training and despite all
our supposed mathematical thinking often
you ask us simple questions and here's a
good example we've got two arrangements
of dots on on a plane on on a piece of
pyramid so from this wonderful book by a
guy called Stephen to your gold bully
for brontosaurus it's page 266 which
one's random Brady which one's entirely
random so I've been asking a lot of
people that very same question Brady and
the vast majority physicists are not
physicists will go this is the random
one and you ask them why and you say
well actually in this one I can see sort
of clusters and groups and chains and
sort of correlations that you know you
wouldn't expect if it was random turns
out this is a random one so the
interesting thing with this is that
there are no spatial correlations here
these points are independent and that
clustering you see is the natural
outcome of something called proton
statistics
rasaan statistics mean that you've got
no relationship no correlation between
those points they're completely
independent of each other in this case
what's actual which looks too many
people looks more random you don't see
the clustering it's not like you can
pull out linear chains or clusters or
even constellations if you think about
the Stars with this one what's happened
is that instead of putting the points
down completely at random which a
computer does here you put the you
choose the points at random but you only
fill in the boxes that way you only fill
in the dark if then surrounding
neighborhood is free of other points so
what we see here is that there was a
natural correlation a natural spatial
relationship between the points here
that isn't there often you know
particularly just in our favorite paper
last week Brady there was another
instance of a story based on seeing the
face of Jesus but the face of Jesus has
been seen in you know tea leaves and
coffee stains and pants and taps and
various many other weird and wacky and
wonderful locations and we scoff at that
and we say well you know of course this
is just random but again it's a question
of what do we mean when we say something
is random and how do we detect and the
way the first thing that physicists turn
to which is sometimes not always the
best way but certainly is the way I love
is something called Fourier analysis and
Fourier analysis is a remarkable method
of basically decomposing images down
into the component parts and looking
looking at them it's like sort of almost
particle physicists physics for images
where you're breaking it down into its
component parts and looking at the
relationship between those various
components and how they build up an
image the very interesting thing is that
you can decompose these images any image
not just these image any image anything
on the Internet can be decomposed down
into a sum of very simple sort of like
the algebra of images very simple sine
waves and so we can I've got a few
examples on screen so what we have here
is a very simple image of a wave where
what we have here is bright dark bright
but as you can see it's a gradation so
what you have is bright intensity here
going down to darken and coming up if we
were to draw a line through this
look at all that intensity varies what
you'd get is a sine wave so this is
effectively a 2-dimensional saying with
okay so that's our basic unit and what
we can do is we can stretch that with we
can increase the frequency of that width
so we can change the number that's a
terrible way but you get the idea we can
change that the frequency and the
wavelength of that way if we can change
the number of waves in a given you know
unit of length and that's actually
something called a spatial frequency so
what we can do is we take this sine wave
and we take this sine wave so this is a
very arbitrary way of adding them
together but you'll see that as I add
them and as I change the orientation of
one with respect to another because this
one is now transparent as I move it it
is it looks pretty cool it looks quite
psychedelic but you know it's that's
sort of what you'd expect it's not the
Mona Lisa but what's remarkable is that
as I said you can break any image down
into those type of waves and physicists
do this all the time astronomers do this
all the time in terms of the for example
the Cosmic Microwave Background how do
you analyze that you see blobs what are
you actually going to pull information
out of that and we spend our life
looking at images around us we need to
quantify those images it's okay to
eyeball something and say well there's a
pattern there but how do you actually
know there's a partner where we've seen
that you know you can of clusters
forming very easily just purely from a
random process what we're gonna do here
we're gonna build up an image right so
that's actually four components four
different waves added together just with
different orientations perhaps different
frequencies different amplitudes boring
what we're going to do now is just add
more and more waves together maybe nine
still looks fairly boring that's nine
waves so let's go to 64 starting to see
something coming out remember all we're
doing is taking those breaking that
image down into separate waves and
adding them up that's all we're doing
nothing more sophisticated than that and
let's see we go to let's go to a hundred
this time does it start to become a
little bit
ignitable maybe I'll add some more
components and but I hope you can see
the ripples the waves and it's not just
this out stress it's not just this image
it's any image we can do this with ok
that was 400 waves and we have to think
about there's a very clever way of
actually adding those waves together and
this is what Fourier analysis tells us
Fourier analysis tells us how much of
the first wave you need how much of the
second wave third fourth and how you
change the fears of those waves the
relationship how you change the
frequencies so I'm pretty something
ironic about you doing is to have if
there is I'm quite happy at the moment
look I moved office I've got a wonderful
view at a wonderful new view it's not
the carpark so I'm sure it's the
greenery that some made me made me happy
the question is then how do you work out
weather or special correlations there
how do you work out whether these points
are related well one way of doing it is
that you look at the waves that make up
the image and if those waves by breaking
down the image into those waves you can
you have a quantitative measure of just
you know basically you can compare the
Fourier components of two images and
from that you can work out what the
degree of randomness effectively is so
what we would do is we'd look at for
example the amplitudes of the waves that
we need to recreate the image and the
frequency all right and if it's entirely
random we don't see any particular peaks
however if it's not random which means
that there's a particular correlation
length there's a particular feature
spacing which is more common than the
rest then what we'll see not so on a
scale is a pink of some description yeah
that's good say the Mona Lisa yep you'd
have a very distinct looking you would
indeed you'd have a very distinct
looking tick and it's not just okay this
is a very simple image let's let's work
in another image
let's do say nine Fourier components
very indistinct let's go for let's go
for 36 components start look familiar
looks like this looks like Elvis
okay let's go 464 better put you out of
your misery and let's go for say one
hundred and forty four components oh
yeah handsome indeed indeed so let's do
a few more go for a thousand a thousand
not a particularly well-written bit of
cold for those of you who would be picky
about the clothes there we go and you
can still see if we were added in more
components you get more more but you can
see it works
so even didn't we could that we could
end it there what this technique of
Fourier analysis tells you is that
actually to make a wavelet looks like
that you have to add a whole bunch of
sine waves together and in the middle
here they all interfere with each other
in a constructive way so they all end up
together